From the very beginning, we believed the impossible is possible.
We promised that we would connect minds and create the future.
And together, we did.
Together, we overcame the inconceivable.
Together, we built the unprecedented.
And together, we showed the world...
...what the best of humanity can achieve.
To every one of the 24 million guests that walked through our gates,...
...to each of the 192 nations that welcomed the world with us,...
...every child whose eyes widened,...
...every volunteer who offered a helping hand,...
...and every heart that helped make Expo a reality,...
...we say "thank you".
Thank you for every smile.
Thank you for every moment.
Thank you for every memory.
We've achieved everything we ever imagined.
We dreamed.
We dared.
We astonished.
And this is just the beginning of the new world...
...we started making together.
We may have closed our doors but our promise still stands.
Connecting minds, creating the future.